الامير المنبوذ هاري اصبح من دون حمايه
شرطيه في بريطانيا بقرار قضائي وذلك بعد
رفض اقاض في لندن قطعنا الذي تقدم به محمد
الامير ضد هذا القرار الحكومي قاضيه
المحكمه العليا اعتبر ان الحكومه
البريطانيه لم تتجاوز سلطتها عندما حرمته
من توفير الحمايه له خلال تواجده في
المملكه المتحده الحكومه البريطانيه توقفت
عن توفير حمايه شرطيه للامير هاري وزوجه
ميجان بعد تخليهما عن واجباتهما الملكيه
وانتقالهما الى كاليفورنيا عام 2020
محامي الحكومه علق انه لا ينبغي ان يسمح
الضباط الشرطه بالعمل كحراس شخصيين
للاثرياء هاري من جهتي اكد انه لا يشعر
بالامانه اثناء زيارته البريطانيا مع
اطفاله الصغار واستند الى ما يقوم به
مصور البابراتسي